last week on this show we covered the
sentencing of Roger stone who is perhaps
the most undeserving of all the many
casualties of the Russia collusion
hysteria stone received more than three
years in prison he'll be over 70 when he
gets out officially his crime was lying
about emails emails that were themselves
entirely harmless from the first day
Stone's prosecution was a transparent
political hit job Washington wanted him
imprisoned because for 40 years he was
Donald Trump's closest political adviser
Amy Berman Jackson is the federal judge
who oversaw the case she was appointed
by Barack Obama she is an openly
partisan Democrat she's made no attempt
to hide that Jackson allowed the foreman
of the jury to lie about her political
background which a normal court of law
would have disqualified her immediately
but Jackson let her stay and then
defended her then Jackson herself lied
about the case she claimed that stone
had been prosecuted because he quote
covered up for the president when in
fact the charges against Roger stone had
nothing to do with that
Amy Berman Jackson is a disgrace to the
judiciary it's frightening that in a
country like ours she has power and she
does we said that on this show last week
today during a hearing Jackson attacked
us and once again she lied as she did it
Jackson accused the show of quote
invading the privacy of the foreman of
the jury when in fact the juror herself
has spoken publicly and revealed her own
identity many media outlets published
her name including the New York Times
The Washington Post and CNN all of which
of course Jackson approves of because
they're on her side then Jackson accused
this show of quote harassing the jurors
even encouraging violence against them
that is insane of course we did no such
thing finally Jackson called our
criticism of her quote antithetical to
our system of justice end quote
which proves that not only is Amy Berman
Jackson corrupt dishonest and
authoritarian and she is definitely all
of those things she also has no sense of
self-awareness whatsoever
Jean Pierre O host justice with judge
Jeanine and she joins us tonight
judge thanks so much for coming on can
you imagine a federal judge in the
middle of a very serious proceeding and
the question in hand was does Roger
stone deserve a new trial because of the
partisanship of the
the form of the jury in the middle of
that lashing out with political attacks
against a TV show that she went after
the president by name what does that say
about her well you know tucker i sat as
a judge in criminal felony cases as well
this is federal but I I'm stunned at her
behavior number one any judge who
concerns herself with the media or the
press needs to get a thick skin or at
least we're a few roads to make it look
like she has thick skin all right she
should not be worried about you or
anyone else she's got a job and she
needs to stay in her Lane but everything
that you've said about her is accurate
and right on point she is a judge who
should be outraged that a foreperson on
a jury that convicted a man on seven
counts may have lied to her may have
exhibited such jury bias that it would
demand a new trial but no she's mad at
you she's mad at the president she wants
to have a hearing on whether or not
those jury bias in private because she
doesn't want anyone intimidating the
jury who here's the bottom line the
juror four person herself outed herself
we know that she is an anti-trump person
she has posted many things about Donald
Trump about Russia about Roger stone at
least once and she is a partisan she ran
for Congress this is a kind of stuff
that we seek to find out in a war dear
this judge should be outraged not at
anyone other than that juror and the
fact that she decided that she wouldn't
recuse herself when she has already
prejudged the issue by saying this jury
acted with integrity and intelligence
how do you know judge - have you spoken
to that juror do you know what was
posted do you know how she answered the
question what do you know about her
background did she want to get on that
jury and everything in my gut tells me
she wanted to get on that jury and
denied no doing anything that was
partisan shame on the judge
shame on Lizzy should be impeached she's
corrupt she's out of control and she's
also muzzled Roger stone taken away his
First Amendment rights he's not allowed
on this show she's threatened to send
him to prison if he defends himself
meanwhile I was being attacked daily by
CNN right
can that happen in this country I don't
understand we've never heard of anything
like this we've never heard of a
defendant who has been convicted and
sentenced and and be then told he can't
talk
his lawyers can't talk we'll put him in
jail she is a partisan she is the one
who put a Paul Manafort in solitary
confinement when everybody I know in the
legal community was this guy why should
why is he in solitary confinement she is
a partisan everything that she has done
including her refusal to recuse herself
not even having a hearing about that
criticizing you when she should be
worried about the fact that she is a
juror for person who's out there saying
I am upset that the Attorney General
decided that this sentence should be
less the sentence miss Hart has nothing
to do with you you decide the facts and
this judge is on the wrong side of
justice in this case she has aligned
herself with someone who may have
disrupted justice in a courtroom and she
has prejudged it and taken the side of
that person it's wrong it's wrong and
her whole here trying to someone like
that sits on a federal bench Roger stone
needs a pardon and let's let's get past
this that's my view judge gene great DC
tonight
thanks so much to see you bye